boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on sockin
pumped to be talking about the future of
comedy positive comedy content creation
self-actualization
we have Joey Avery joining us on the
show how are we I love good to see you
it's been a minute it's been a minute
it's good to see you again
yes huge thank you for coming onto the
show super pumped we have a lot to talk
about a horse for those who don't know
Joey Avery's been a comedian now for six
years he's also doing content production
with shelby's he's also has two podcasts
one with Chubby's one called Pier 69 his
his list of events is just pop pop pop
pop that he's going and doing comedy at
he's got some acting under spell he's
got all this cool stuff we're gonna talk
about this triple-threat I don't know
anything above triple so I just leave it
there I have many skills I can cook a
little bit you know ladies Joey okay we
love starting off the show with the big
history perspective on things all right
so after a long period of evolution
humans find themselves as stewards of
Earth aha we're we're hockey sticking up
in population exponential technology
what is the current synthesis on the
state of humanity the current synthesis
on the state well I'm glad you started
off with such an easy question which
obviously I've prepared for I think you
know on the spot I think that humanity
right now is at a point where we feel
because we're seeing so much content all
the time like things are at a boiling
point and like we're about to blow and
maybe we are or maybe statistically it's
actually a very good time to be alive
but because we're drowning and stuff all
the time
we just think everything's about to go
bad I don't know the answer but I feel
like everyone is freaking out a lot
right now
and I think that if you look back at
history that was always the case and
we've always been freaking out and maybe
it'll be okay that's what I think
there's a very strange thing when you
think about the biological creature like
the primate rat like oh I'm human I'm
advanced but the primate level we are
totally anxious creatures like the fact
that we're just abiding by social
regulations right now right we're
neither one of us is taking this hot tea
and pouring it on the other one because
we deliver quite honest see you're
walking down the street no one middle fo
you wouldn't want to try that with me no
one just takes their car it's the start
driving it on the sidewalk right right
couple of people here in the air and
that's always scary sometimes old people
will make that move do you think that we
are way overloaded in content then
because of the Exponential's the social
media the instant Ness of all the pocket
computing do you think yeah a big part
of I think it is I mean I don't remember
who did it maybe you would know but I
remember watching a TED talk awhile ago
and they were just talking about
basically the dissemination of
information and how people feel like if
you do surveys people feel like it's the
worst time to be alive but if you look
at statistics in terms of safety
well-being all the things that people
have at their disposal it's by far the
best time to be alive people don't feel
that way because when you go online you
have access to everything that happens
and horrible horrible things happen
every day have happened every day will
happen every day but I feel like in my
own life I'll sit there and think well I
should I should be informed about what's
going on I should go on my phone and go
through and look for stuff or if I'm
writing jokes see what's going on and
after 30 minutes for that I want to
drive my car onto the sidewalk I start
freaking out and then you slow down and
you think is my life in a good spot
there are people that I love in my life
do I have the you know ability
personally in my current situation to
chase a dream and do what I want to do
even if that gets stressful sometimes
that's an amazing
thing and you shouldn't take that for
granted otherwise this is gonna fly
right by you and it's gonna be over and
you'll miss the whole point mmm oh
that's such a good entry into the self
actualization conversation just in a
moment to back up there this is
extremely important this notion that we
live in the best times in terms of
ubiquity and water shelter food internet
education healthcare everything is
already here made by a hundred billion
people before us and so to have
gratitude for that and to realize that
we now have all these tools for us to be
able to find what we care about what
yeah brings us the most meaning and
pursue that it's so crucial the angels
of our nature Steven Pinker the argument
there's been many talks now about this
is the best time to be alive yeah the
penicillin it's beyond ranks there's so
many thin condoms the pill no condoms
listen so I just I think yeah I think
that what people are reacting to a
little bit is when computers started to
you know come out and the internet came
online people were so excited and
especially in you know San Francisco
Silicon Valley where we are and where I
grew up there was this prognostication
about how this is going to be the best
thing ever
and then what people are realizing is
it's kind of so worse divisions it seems
to have made politics worse and so
people are going oh maybe this is
actually the worst thing because we're
thinking about it all the time but I
think that if you can take a depends on
that's swinging back and forth but if
you can take a second and just think
about the bigger picture instead of the
immediate moment and at least take a
personal perspective of realizing you
can't control everything and thinking
everything is a positive and a negative
but taking a position of gratitude
towards some of the opportunities that
you do have you'll live a much better
life just by putting your focus on that
understanding that there are still
massive problems it doesn't mean oh the
internet saved everything now there's no
poor people in the world of this country
but
position of gratitude for where you're
at and trying to use that to help make
things better instead of freaking out
all the time yo you know the ways that
we can uh still unleash the next
iterations of the Internet and
exponential technology to maximize
imagination and creativity which was one
of the things that we came to the social
media generation with that this internet
is going to enable us to prove to the
greatest flourishing of imagination
creativity okay this is this is
interesting because when I watched your
commencement speech 2013 UC San Diego
flow going on beautiful hair the flow
was happening then is preening yeah and
everyone's got to watch that I'm telling
you it's one of my I'm serious it's one
of my favorites because for commencement
talk because I think you actually hit on
one of the most important things which
is this idea of self actualization
you're like engineers you guys already
know what you're gonna be doing right
for the next couple years in rich
I already got like six jobs lined AHA
offers and then a bunch of other like a
majority of people are still figuring
themselves out when they're leaving
school when they're leaving high school
or when they're in the mid-20s whatnot
so I want you to teach us about you had
this interesting study abroad in South
Africa as well yeah and I want you to
kind of tell us about that
and about how you ended up giving that
commencement speech why
self-actualization is so important yeah
so I was very fortunate enough to have
the experience to live in Cape Town
South Africa for six months at the end
of my time in college and that was just
one of those moments where you know I
kind of picked a place where I was like
this is I don't know anyone I think he's
been there maybe one or two people it's
the opposite side of the world you know
if I can get out there you know my
thought obviously there are many reasons
I chose that I was always very
interested in in Mandela and read a lot
of books on him and thought you know it
was an interesting historical place
because it was you know dealing with
apartheid ending not too
long ago and I felt like living in the
United States it would be kind of
helpful to go somewhere where was almost
like segregation just ended and just
have that feeling kind of more intensely
which was intense
but when I you know went over there one
of my main goals was hey I'm getting off
that you know an airplane some metal
tube on the other side of the world
about as far away as I can possibly go
why don't I use this moment to try
everything I've never tried or to
reinvent myself no one here knows me you
know I was running from everything but I
think everyone wants a rebirth every
once in a while and when I was out there
I they had a program where you could
have a radio show so I had a radio show
at University of Cape Town and then a
friend of mine found an open mic for
comedy and was like you should try this
out because he'd heard me on the radio
and I was like I should try it out and
so I you know pull up my room and
watched a bunch of specials and then you
wrote you know my seven minutes and went
up and did it and got offstage once and
I was like that's it that's what I'm
doing it was the mix of everything that
I'd always wanted to do when I was a kid
but I never had put it quite all
together and then the second I did
stand-up I was like oh it all fits you
know it's a you get it's almost like
philosophy you get paid to think
it's obviously not nearly as actually
good because a lot of it's BS and you
know false logic but it's great and it's
fun being funny and performing all these
things that I that I always like to do
you there's so there's a couple of
important things there first is this
apartheid I want you to teach us about
that because then we'll get to kind of
this comedy and why it's so meaningful
to you and how we can get that to more
people but let's start with the
apartheid what's that actually like to
go there in 2013 mm yeah you know I my
experience with it obviously is not the
experience that people who actually live
through it were so I just kind of got to
go there and just observe you know where
I saw the tensions and kind of went to
some different museums there's like a
district six museum where you get to go
into one of the townships which is
basically or going to one of the cities
that was you know
for minority communities they just had
to uproot and leave and they have all
these different artifacts from that time
which is which is very interesting and
then you know I got to teach in what
they call they have townships out there
they're basically like different kind of
ghettos and so I got to go out there and
teach and just see what what life is
like for a lot of the communities that
have been you know left behind by the
progress that South Africa has which is
also the you know the most well-off
nation in in Africa but still has
obviously quite a lot of problems so it
was interesting you know I did obviously
didn't have an insane first-hand
experience but anytime you go somewhere
for a brief time you know I was there
for six months but by the time I left as
a call I think I'm just starting to
understand this a little bit you know
you come away from that just with a with
a broader perspective is it a dichotomy
of haves and have-nots that is greater
than the United States is most like
Rincon Hill and Bay View right or
Tenderloin right it feels like it you
know more it is more visually because
you can go to a certain area that's you
know four or five star resorts and it's
a beach town and everyone's having fun
and then on the way there you're driving
past and you're on the road and you can
see an entire area where it's like you
know shacks just kind of hand-built with
you know metal roofing and kind of like
Jimmy rig like you know dishes and stuff
like that so it's a little more visual
than some of the poverty that you see in
the US which is more like you know
high-rises but you can tell they're kind
of beat down and then maybe there's some
super millionaires living in San
Francisco but they don't have the most
ostentatious house outwardly but I think
I don't know but I would assume
statistically it's worse there well I
wanna at the very end I want to circle
back to wealth inequality and here's
some of your thoughts on it let's talk
about that feeling that you had when
you're out there you're performing you
have that moment for yourself when
you're like I love this feeling is that
a combination of the audience and making
them laugh and what you feel from the
yeah thank creatively yeah I mean that's
just that's the best feeling in the
world is to be up there saying stuff and
it works and you just like the first
time you get that you just feel that
energy just moving through and you're
like oh I'm the I'm the man you know and
you tell the next joke and it just eats
and play the vision you're just like
okay then you start like talking a
little bit faster and then at the end
you gotta get off and at least the first
time you kind of get off and you're like
like um you know you're like feeling
kind of like crazy like I think that
went well and then you know one of your
like two drunk friends comes up she was
like you were amazing you're like maybe
I am amazing
I was the dumbest dude I you know I did
one set seven minutes and I was okay
I'll write some new material come back
in two weeks come back in two weeks do
an entirely different seven minutes and
I'm bringing like 15 to 20 students out
and like it's a big party and like both
of them objectively were like for a
first and second time decent but went
okay and had major misses and but got
through it and we're like decent and I
in my dumb head I get off and I'm like
alright so I have 14 minutes of my hour
ready I just got to get to 60 from here
I can get back stateside start shopping
it around to HBO and then you know you
realize what actual comedy is like and
you realize it takes years to grind out
like your first good five minutes and
then you know build from there okay and
as we get to that let's talk about
self-actualization you know when you
come back and you're giving this
commencement speech you're all about
really trying to get people's awareness
expanded to the fact they can be the
best version of themselves yeah and you
kind of embody that now you're becoming
the best version of yourself so teach us
about that yeah well I hope so you know
I mean I think for everyone of course
that's a daily struggle that's a that's
a process thing like you never get to
that point where you're like I'm God now
so let's do this yeah the way that I got
to do the speech I it was just an open
competition like I had a friend of mine
who's like me and I can't believe you
the valedictorian of your college I was
like yeah I wasn't that's not
what that was I did you know I did well
but but yeah it was just it was a
competition I remember I was going
somewhere and and and just like I was
like traveling somewhere and I just sat
down on the plane and was just like I
want to do this and just just wrote
something and sent it in and it got
picked for a next round and and just
kind of went through I think at the time
what I was thinking about was you know
when you're gonna speak at an event
you're thinking what's going on with me
and how does it apply to everyone else
and like because if you're not feeling
it then your speech just BS you know
already no one's gonna care so what I
was thinking about at that time was like
I think I'm in a position where I'm
lucky I've found something that I really
care about and like to do yeah and I
still feel like whatever success that I
achieve in this like that alone is a
gift that I know that a lot of people
wish they had are still searching for
and so that's what I just kind of wanted
to write about was like thinking of
graduation as like hey don't use this
moment to say okay well I guess I have
my fun in college I'm just gonna give up
and do something that I don't want to do
at all or to think like oh great now
like now this is everything's gonna
change now it's like this is just a
ceremony like your life is gonna change
but you need to keep thinking with you
know the advantage that you have right
now is that you are idealistic the
world's going to beat that out of you
but try and not forget that you have
things that excite you and they're worth
doing no matter what you know and
because the second you give up on that
you can just become a you know cynical
crabby you know person that you don't
even like damn that is some wisdom right
there I love that right there yeah so
you you're preaching right now identify
what brings you the most fulfillment in
life and pursue that with the most vigor
and intensity
out of everything else and never put
those things on the back seat because
that's gonna be the greatest regret you
have in life right is not pursuing that
that's where people can become really
in full or upset yeah and actually a lot
of people are starting to realize that
they would rather be poor they would
rather be living bare bones every single
month just getting by but doing what
they love is artists or entrepreneurs
rather than working for other people
doing things they don't like to do right
but I think the important thing with
that is also to be honest with yourself
cuz you might actually be that person
that's like I don't want to be poor I
don't want to struggle I would rather
have this job which I kind of care about
but I know I can make a lot of money and
what I really care about is you know
making that money going to Hawaii
spending time with my friends and family
that can be your choice that's fine you
don't have to like pigeonhole yourself
into being that person who's like
alright think I wanted to write a book
once so now I'm gonna stare at this
blank page and I suck and I don't want
to write this book and then you write a
horrible crappy book and you're like why
did I divorce my wife to do this or
husband yeah great point yeah you know
there's you know the different colors on
the color wheel for people and what they
want to explore in their life you have
to be honest with yourself and you got
to make what whatever you decide to do
you're gonna make some sacrifices if it
is I want to chase this dream you are
gonna sacrifice some free time probably
definitely gonna sacrifice some money
and you're gonna take a big risk kids
right honey yeah and if you go the other
way you might be sacrificing a dream so
you know I don't have that answer but
you got to figure out what you really
want and then once you do realize that
you're taking a risk either way but once
you've taken that risk just realize
that's the life you chose like really no
one chose that for you so whatever
drawbacks that has don't spend your life
being super upset about those things you
chose that life you you know you eat the
plate of [ __ ] you decided to serve can I
say that totally okay
okay so yeah so what now is our current
state of things like we're moving like
six years like you've been working in
comedy doing acting doing content
creation and you're seeing kind of like
of kind of there's a little bit of
missoura of like negativity and
sometimes in comedy and that can be
funny mm-hmm
um at the same time you can definitely
be what's called punching down right
people there's plenty of good material
to punch up right like the amount of
people that literally and like extracted
wealth like a syringe a shareholders
from masses like there's tons of fun to
make right of them for being with the
wealth and equality right with maniacs
sometimes so so how do you have this
positive culture of comedy well it's
funny so like I you know we were talking
about a little bit before this started
but I I do think in in comedy which is
kind of sometimes almost by necessity a
little bit kind of a negative art form
because it's so funny to be negative
it's so like they got you walk outside
and like there's one rain cloud over
your head and then a semi drives by and
it splashes you with water and then like
you know someone breaks up with you and
someone kicks you in the balls like
that's hilarious
that's so funny and I think comedians
are always thinking and thinking and
thinking and thinking and if you're just
thinking all the time you know you're
gonna get negative it's not like a
meditative like yoga thing where you're
like oh my god I like ascended to this
higher plane of bliss like that's not
what comedy is it was hard to make
comedy positive but the other important
thing with comedies you're supposed to
find your own voice and I've never liked
of course I'm like anyone else I get sad
you know depressed I get negative all
the time and sometimes I'm funny when I
am negative but at general as a person
if I'm trying to think how I compare to
most people I don't consider myself that
way I consider myself a positive person
and I have to consider myself that way
because otherwise I wouldn't be happy
you know so trying to make comedy
positive for me
it's trying to basically like even if a
joke is negative or a punchline is
negative bring it around at the end to
like I'm looking at it because you're
examining something with a joke I'm
gonna examine this thing I'm gonna look
at it maybe in a very negative way and
light it up and all that funnies in
there but really at the end I can kind
of pull it around to make a slightly
broader point which doesn't waste too
much time not being funny but can
hopefully give people you know a window
into the fact that my mind isn't like
awful you know and punching up and
punching down is it different converse
is very interesting
like you said I think that like you know
punching up is like a good way to like
use comedy for social change and all of
that and some people would say that like
it's not cool to punch down I think
punching down can be really funny but I
every joke like I don't yeah I try to
make no I try not to make too many rules
about comedy because you can make
something funny and I hate I hate and
this happens in San Francisco I'll lead
into a joke and maybe it'll feel a
certain way and I've written it in a
certain way where it comes back around
and you're not gonna hate me at the end
of the joke not Who I am
but when I set it up people are off
board already and it's like do you know
what comedy is give me time to explain
it a lot of times comedy is setting up
something that sounds awful and then
like defending it with logic until
people are like oh my god I've never
thought of it that way it's kind of
funny and then maybe at the end giving
people something sweet that like feels
good at the end like that's gotta give
it some time that's a really good point
is that to let the artists do the work
and see where it got to see where it's
guided and not be close-minded openness
is a really important trait that's a
great way to be able to process new
ideas and change minds etc okay you
started talking about political
correctness and I always have now we
have to divest a little bit so there's
there's this idea that if you're not
building up your immune system to being
able to take a joke
then even if it is like punching down if
someone is
trying to make complete fun of like how
hairy I am because I'm a hairy chin
masonary very hairy insane and show us
yeah that should be your patreon you
should start a patreon and be like if
you donate $10 a month I'll mail you a
box of my belly bears yeah maybe it's
worth a shot in one person probably well
you've got plenty of supplies so as many
people want to get out there you know he
could you could support hundred
thousands wants to see see so one has to
be able to know how to accept this the
joking on themselves and that this is
part of being able to grow up and play
with other humans yet with other
primates yeah because if one becomes so
coddled in a bubble that they can't take
any of this they won't build their
immune system up and they won't be able
to play and engage with other humans
so do you kind of like that building up
the immune system mentality for I I do I
mean I think you know but it's it's
funny with comedy because it's always
been known as this thing where people
can kind of shatter norms and say crazy
stuff and that is what it is but it's
ultimately it's a part of an industry
which is political leanings are taking
it very far away from a place where that
is acceptable so it's it's a fine line
to walk because on the one hand like I
said people being so politically correct
that they can't take a joke at all is is
difficult to comedy I mean Dave
Chappelle in one of his latest specials
was saying like comedians like it is
your job to say some reckless [ __ ] right
and I think that's true and at what I
asked for is the space for us to say
that reckless [ __ ] and try and defend it
and for people to not get offended out
of hand without giving it any time that
said there are some things where you can
also say something and be wrong and then
if someone gets offended by it because
everyone split into either
I'm PC or PC is all bs
then the second one of those moments
happens people just run into their camps
and some people are like oh this PC
culture is [ __ ] it's like sometimes
you can say something which is wrong and
you might have to get dragged for that
as a comic or you know whatever and
that's kind of the life you chose as
well like you have to do it's a if it's
a free marketplace of ideas sometimes
you have a bad one and sometimes people
are gonna come after that so it's always
a case-by-case basis I just I think that
what people have lost a lot is the
benefit of the doubt for anyone that
they perceive as not being on their side
we can even go through an example of if
you were to potentially try and teach
people about how horrendous it was of
the enslavement of so many Africans
around the world and you can walk them
through a process of what it was
actually like to do something like that
and then at the very end be like listen
that's them one of the most [ __ ] up
things that's ever happened on this
planet right right and so you there's
like a different way like if you're
gonna explain what it's like to be
someone that's completely poor today
right it doesn't even have barely
anything to eat that has to still walk
to a well for their water and you walk
them through that process and you're
cracking jokes about it the whole time
right and then at the very end you're
saying like we got to fix that
inequality because that would suck to be
in their shoes right so these are the
types of things that be hilarious bit I
mean I think that a scenario like that
what's interesting about that is while
you're talking about that what I'm
thinking is what a part of comedy is
realizing like sometimes you only have
five minutes in front of a room and you
need to realize how they're gonna
perceive you immediately because
whatever comes out of your mouth is
filtered through whatever they've judged
you as immediately and I don't think
that means you should never like talk
about other experiences or talk about
things that you're not because half of
comedy is talking about like different
groups of people and how we all think
age together as a culture but as you're
saying that I don't think there would be
anything wrong with doing that and it
really depends on how the bid is written
but as you're saying that like when I go
to open my notebook I usually think like
a crowd probably for better or for worse
and whether or not I want to do this
work is up to me sex a crowd probably
doesn't want to hear me talk about
slavery right it's like it's not like I
had anything to do with that but it's
not something that people are probably
looking forward to hearing me talk about
because a if I'm joking about it it's
gonna be tense and B if I'm just
preaching about it people are like yeah
that's a real original point that you
think slavery is bad we're just trying
to like the newest sort of displacement
of people though Roe Higgins and so
there's a massive like over 1 million
refugees right now been moved from me
and more from the coast to refugee camps
in Bangladesh right so very small in the
normal news headlines isn't it exactly
it doesn't it subtract the tops and very
much now we're taking something that is
being missed out of echo chamber news
rights and we are applying it as a there
is comedy there and there is a way to
portray it yeah increase people's
awareness right about a painstaking
situation that would get people to maybe
feel more sometimes the best way to get
people to feel to get behind someone
else's shoes is potentially a immersive
VR experiments potentially having them
meditate on what everybody like to be
them but sometimes it's getting them to
laugh and realize I would can hate to be
in that yeah in their shoes and so now
I'm gonna do something about that right
so this interesting to explore yeah and
there are there are a lot of comics that
will that will absolutely do that and
and whatever you know color of their
skin race gender all that kind of stuff
I do think you could talk about these
things and I have seen comics of all you
know everything talked about things like
slavery and horrible things and kind of
do well the decision that you make is a
comic if yeah it's gonna be part of your
act then you are like okay I'm doing I'm
doing the the political act that because
it's hard to segue from something kind
of like trivial or like oh I'm doing fun
like every day like datings weird you
know and then you're like also so is
genocide how about those row hangings
like that's a very hard switch which
which can be interesting in its own
sense as an artist to be able to switch
like that yeah because then you're
really showing people that you can play
in all different fields the best way to
do that if you're not gonna be talking
about that already is to slide it in
before people realize what's going on
because what happens a lot of times and
everyone has their own style but I do
hate this is when someone just like is
like doing this and then just like pivot
and then just preaches about something
and then gets to an applause break and
like or what people call clapped er
which is like literally just clapping
and laughing just because they feel like
they should because you've made a
powerful point and you everyone in the
room should agree with it and it almost
kind of feels like mind control
sometimes because like the comedy of
that situation is you can feel that
there is a right or a wrong right and
the correct thing to do with comedy in a
situation like the ROE Higgins for
example is to punch up right because you
should use this moment to tell people to
give people a walk in someone else's
shoes and to talk about something that's
horrible and it's in a scenario where
they're not getting much of that
information but the funniest thing to do
probably is to take the other spot which
is horrible but like that's what people
would just like instinctly even if
they're like oh god like you're like you
know I want that coastal land so I'm
gonna go and kill people for that
coastal isn't going to sprites that's
that's the struggle because like
obviously now you're an [ __ ] and like
people don't like you but the struggle
for a comic
is do I want to say what I believe which
is like a good and positive thing which
is a helpful thought which is
constructive which is calling attention
to something important and be kind of
pandering or do I want to just be like
I'm gonna like this makes me laugh
because this is so clearly [ __ ] up
that like I'm just gonna do it and then
take that tag kind of with that little
you know like sneer and I think that a
lot of comics that are really talented
they are able to talk about the horrible
thing in a way that is genuinely funny
that isn't pandering they don't allow
themselves to get those pandering laughs
thanks go dig in they dig in until they
find a unique angle that still is
punching up but it doesn't feel so
painfully obvious that everyone should
be clapping at it you know it's it's
like this wow this is a hilarious bit
and it's based upon us all knowing who's
right in this situation that's that's
what that is I love it because you went
and you showed us a binary view on it
which you have to either go super duper
pandering to everybody or the super
aggressive like completely counter and
then he found that nuanced position I
like how you did that live because then
that shows people that you can be really
funny and still have an interesting
moral arc and perspective to things yeah
let's let's touch a bit because that was
a lot on comedy I think a lot of the
time we don't even kind of understand
that there's a ton of other opportunity
that exists in my space also in acting
also in different types of content
creation you know running these podcasts
doing these little short funny ass
Chubby's of it yeah yeah so yes so tell
us about all that other stuff yeah so
that's you know one of the kind of goals
that I had for the last two years of my
life in San Francisco you know was to
find a way to like actually keep doing
comedy and I'm you know I'm out five six
nights a week generally but find a way
to have it become part of my day job
because back when we met you know I was
doing something totally unrelated
there aren't as many like entertainment
jobs in this town as you can imagine so
but I've always loved podcasts it's like
listening to podcasts as part of what
got me into comedy believe it or not
it's probably at one of the like first
waves of that being the case so Silicon
Valley has a lot of space for comedy
like we have a techie out sure has a lot
of space right and poking fun at it yeah
I should pitch a show called Silicon
Valley to HBO like it there's plenty
more where that needs to be right yeah
there of course is there absolutely is
but so like it really a big goal that I
had was to launch my own podcast and so
a couple things I was able to do we
launched yeah me and three of my other
favorite comics in San Francisco
launched Pier 69 bought the equipment do
it out of my house why'd you pick the
name because we're children the reason
why actually is because the the premise
of that show is is to say like like I
said I'd like to personally I like to
veer kind of like a little more positive
all these things our idea was like let's
see if we can make our like most
completely uncensored unscented it's
things that I would never say by myself
or in polite company or probably
shouldn't put on the internet let's just
roll out the mics and just do that every
week and let's do it from a place that
basically insensitive comedy in kind of
a sensitive place is the premise of that
show and so pier 69 pier 39 is obviously
a big San Francisco things 69 is a very
stupid immature joke we're not above it
it's an REITs exposition yes yeah yeah
that's a mouthful but we kind of wanted
people to know going in like if if that
type of joke offends you or is beneath
you like maybe don't like check it out
so that that's been a lot of fun you
started that up you said just like a
couple guys with mics yeah they like I
ran to Guitar Center one day with like a
backpack and like just like put stuff in
and got like you know came home and set
that up and then I love that constant
creation I like the stories about how
people get started yeah in the space
it's still a big land grab with the
attention economy and so if you can real
people in and teach them interesting
things and build an audience that way
that's good but like you pointed out
earlier sometimes it's not for everyone
to pursue these types of things right
right and it is tough I mean it's it's
tough to get people's attention there
are many award-winning podcasts set I I
don't know what are their podcast Awards
who cares there's a lot of like really
good podcasts out there that I'll never
hear cuz there's another new one pops up
every day so you get people who really
like you and cool thing is when people
start to enjoy what you do you're a part
of their life you're their commute you
know you're there
they're doing dishes whatever you're in
their ear it's this weird like intimate
things yeah and it's a new medium yeah
which is crazy grind it feels great it's
interesting as we never got radio would
become podcast would write piggyback on
what radio was and now with because the
super computers are in our pockets yeah
and we have it in everywhere we go then
that makes it so much easier to just
tune into the voice being I can record
on my phone and post verses I need a
radio station right soon now it's
democratized yeah it's it's it's a
really cool thing in the thing with
something being democratized is anyone
can do it right so we just for it it's
figured it out we're doing that on the
flip side I you know was able to I went
to some conference and I saw one of the
content creators good friend Mason speak
and he was from Chubby's and I just saw
the videos they made and how they're
like you know we are a a company that
obviously they were like kind of brought
back short shorts in their men's apparel
company we obviously sell a lot more
than that but the way he pitched it to
this conference I was at was he was just
saying like we consider ourselves also a
an entertainment company and I was like
this doesn't exist it's gonna like how
can I get my foot in the door I went
home right after this and just drafted
an email brought my comedy clip grabbed
the commencement speech you know put
everything and and one thing led to
another and and now I'm there yes it's
great that's how you do it when you find
something you love you got a package it
up like that get after it that's really
great and actually that's a huge
testament to the future of media in
general is if you have a clothing line
you better know how to be a yummy
entertaining mission-driven organization
to stay relevant yeah and I you know we
have so the Chubby's podcast we have is
like it's a it's a business podcast and
we were able to get like top in the
business charts last week and we had
this kind of exciting week but it's not
business we don't talk about business at
all we literally it's an hour of comedy
and we barely the only time we address
that we're gonna do business we're like
oh yeah we'll get to that and that we
never do so we kind of like like faking
you know what we do but there's where do
you guys manufacture your clothes
what's your customer acquisition come
right exactly we're gonna cover the
white papers at the end of the show but
first I'm gonna do monologue joke so we
do physical challenges where people are
chopping wood and I'm announcing it like
a sportscaster and it's like it's man
right but that is that is now what yeah
that's our little that's our little
timer for the 15 minute go that's a cool
and it's classic there's an old timer
right there I feel like I'm in a lab oh
my god I'm gonna watch this I feel like
my life is slipping through my hands but
but you know that's it's like again
you're you're competing for people's
entertainment and like I don't even
consider that marketing I consider that
putting on a comedy variety hour show
with some of my good friends and the fan
base that they've already built because
we just make stuff that people like and
hopefully those people find that and
they really like the clothes or vice
versa and they kind of come in to
listening to us that way you just you
know we there's so much content out
there we're hit with stuff all the time
if you can't be genuine if people can't
feel where you're coming from if they
don't
like you you're not gonna you're not
gonna do well no matter what you're
selling you could be selling shorts you
could also be you know what we're doing
here we're competing for someone's
attention they're shutting off their own
thoughts for an hour which it might be
nice for some of you you know all of us
sometimes you're like I don't want that
yeah right now I want to learn about a
specific topic right and if I want to
learn about what the future potentially
of positive comedy or content creation
is like right B I do want to tune in so
I can find myself at the edge exploring
as well you know you I want I want to
ask you on on the way out I want to ask
you a couple things I find that we don't
have the right funnels for youth to pick
up comedy and there seem to be a couple
maybe potentially reasons why there's no
like middle school and high school
comedy showcases but teach us about this
what's up with these funnels they're not
really in place for for we've seen
sometimes 14 year olds take the big
stage and like I do really well poking
fun at adult white butts right and high
school life or whatever so yeah tell us
about this cuz I would find it really
interesting to try and actualize more
young people into into this field it
seems to be one of the ones that's gonna
get automated much later yeah right yeah
so there's I mean there are obviously an
example of a successful comedian who
started yeah I think that the I think
the funnel now honestly for young kids
is YouTube like if you think about if
you hear me at least I don't know I
don't hang out with its creators but
like whenever I hear kids that age talk
is astounding how many of them are like
man I want to be a youtuber when I grow
up I'm like when you grow up there's a
computer there's a camera on your
computers
start doing it but the first person to
do that or one of the first people to do
that was Bo Burnham and he was a young
kid who started making kind of funny
funky songs in his room and recording
them and they blew up and he blew up as
the
platform YouTube blew up he was an early
adopter and he became this incredible
sensation and he actually just made a
movie called eighth grade right yeah I
think for that exact reason I think he
is the embodiment of like creating kind
of that funnel ER or trying to do that I
think the reason that we don't see many
of those funnels one I think that a lot
of kids are doing YouTube and I I don't
know if that's a really good thing or
not but if you want to do that I
remember running around making jackass
videos with my friends on a camcorder
punching each other in the face and you
know draggin each other buying cars and
all that kind of stuff so if it kids
interested in something you gotta let
him do it you just kind of hope they
don't become famous and break their
brains but as far as like actually
getting up on a stage and doing stand-up
I think a 8th graders - most eighth
graders are so mortally afraid of what
people think of them that to get up and
own a room is almost impossible
- what they think is funny is [ __ ] up
often times thank you weird the mind of
an eighth-grader like look it I have
found some like old Facebook messages
that I said when I was in 8th absolutely
bad stuff some interesting things yeah
and the third thing I think that would
you know again if a kid starts doing
comedy to young age they're gonna be out
of the game and it could be could end up
being a very good thing but I think part
of comedy a lot of times is having a
slightly more adult perspective on
things and even I started when I was I
think 21 or so and even as of a few
years ago I talked to one of the
Booker's that had a major you know Club
here before I had passed there and he
kind of said he was having some
conversations with some people about
where I was at and was like oh this is
funny like he's got what it takes but
you know he he's not talking about
anything yet because he hasn't really
experienced anything for sure so
patronizing view to take of 8th graders
they're going through more intense like
drama all the time every day
but sometimes they don't have the
developed kind of like brain and logic
to be like why don't I filter this and
that'll work how many of those young
people are being creatively squelched by
the high noise to signal ratio so they
are struggling with creatively
expressing themselves via these mediums
now because there's too many posts on
Instagram and Twitter and YouTube and
one yeah which make it much more
difficult for them to find a way to vote
of vocally or through writing or through
auditory or video actualize themselves
in that way okay a couple quick powwows
on the way out because there's these
you're right though I mean even when I'm
like looking at my phone and then I
think I try to create stuff you just
start wanting to like mimic people so
you if you want to do something creative
sometimes you need to shut it down and
like I'm addicted all the time I check
it all the time it's more than I should
but I put it away enough that I can get
some space so that you're not mimicking
when you're trying to throttle it so you
can hyper focus on your creativity
deleting apps is very powerful
reclaiming your mind from the attention
economy and power 'fl one has to set
those conscious goals and follow up on
them power around what would you say is
a core driving principle of your life
you know I I think this is like so
cliche and obvious but to me it is being
being happy but also considering what
long-term happiness means and knowing
that that's not like a constant state
it's like an ideal to try and move
towards and realizing that sometimes
happiness is going out to a bar and
getting drunk with your friends right I
love that sometimes happiness is going
to the gym focusing on Fitness happiness
can be doing things for other people
doing things that fulfill yourself
reading watching think think whatever
feeds you for like a deep feeling of I
don't even know if it's happiness but I
guess it kind of is it's happiness and
self-actualization and and feeling like
you're the best version of yourself
because I don't think that's a state
that you necessarily have to achieve I
think it's a state that's kind of within
you and you need to figure out what
things you need
to do that can bring you to that place
where you feel that that's good what
would you what would you recommend as a
principle for society to feel more of
the collective of the unity feeling that
we so need yeah I I think and and this
isn't the exact answer but I think that
we mentioned it earlier in this if you
try to start your day or have a check in
with yourself at some point in the day
and focus on having a feeling of
gratitude for the things that you do
have not just the things that you're
trying to get it will put you in a
position where you will feel better
about yourself and you will also feel
better about other people and instead of
thinking oh I don't have this I want you
know you're already grateful for what
you do have that's gonna make you see
maybe someone else's perspective with an
easier light it might make you see a
comic start a joke that you think you're
gonna hate and you are a little less so
you give them a little more time you
know if you can focus on being great
before you have I think you cut other
people a little more slack and hopefully
that would allow people to calm down a
little bit got a focus on the life I
live I love that gratitude can
definitely inspire a lot of love and a
lot of compassion and a lot of
collective thinking I like that a lot
all right last - mm-hmm are we in a
simulation aha
I should have known I should have known
it was coming uh I think that there is
this is gonna be like the least like
brainy answer I think that there's a lot
of if you read books about it if you
understand how advanced we're getting at
creating alternate realities and how
indistinguishable they may and will
become from human life and how that
could have happened before and how you
can like look at like seeing like
patterns of code and mathematics and the
underlying symmetry of the universe you
could see all of that and then still I'd
be like I don't think so because
I I just some things and I hate like gut
feeling people because people's guts
tell them some wacky ass [ __ ] and
sometimes it's but maybe it just works
for me I feel like I can know this is
real and maybe even this is the most
important thing even if it is a
simulation it's the only real thing I've
ever known and so this everything that
I've been told life is is real to me
whether or not someone's like you know
doing it and I hope hey maybe if there's
someone up there playing the game and
he's got Joey Avery and I'm his
character I hope that guy's I hope I
hope I hope you're good I hope you're
good at this game
trying to win you're trying like we said
earlier you're trying to level up to be
the best your character can possibly be
in this game in this reality right but I
I just I gotta believe that you know I
am a real being in a real space that has
some some power of self and I feel it to
be true so I'm gonna [ __ ] stick with
it your entire preface was like this is
super code it's all code it's all
indistinguishable realities right but if
there is a higher intelligence in the
universe right and if you can have an
experience through intense meditation or
psychedelics or all these things that
reveal these truths to you and you can
feel it and whether that's in your brain
or whether it's something out there or
whether it's a simulation and it's math
and you can see all these things the
simulation and a god
could be the same description definitely
we talk about that a lot people always
temptin to say do you believe in God
it's like well why don't we come up with
these interesting ways to define it
could it be all that is right any
consciousness or divinity or infinity or
so many right describe it last question
yeah last question what's the most
beautiful thing in the world there's dad
- what is the most be the most beautiful
thing in the world is love and it is and
it is everywhere and everyone has it and
when you give it to people it works I
mean and it expresses itself through
many things if you said that it was a
particular painting that was probably
done with some sort of love or care it
can be love for a passion love for
yourself love for someone else anything
that is the blanket concept that is that
answer immediately
that was really well described I think
it's right there in so many different
ways yeah yeah and it's and it's it's
fleeting I mean it's hard sometimes you
sometimes you feel very far from it you
know and and some people struggle with
that more than others everyone struggles
with it to some point and so that's why
it's important to find the things that
you love and like I said for some people
that is the hustle and the grind some
people it's work in a certain amount and
then you know going traveling whatever
it is spending time with their people
you you got to find the things that you
love you got to fight for those things
and and that's pretty much all you can
do Jo Avery what a freaking pleasure
this is this is great thanks Alan thanks
for coming on the show scores for fun
yeah a lot of good stuff there we
couldn't potentially explore doing a
peer 69 video on sectors mark and Andrew
we were dangers already on the line of
marks we've been aiming to get him on
yeah let's yeah maybe we do that that
may that be wild that would be that
would things would be this has been
great a lot to think about
thanks everyone we greatly appreciate
you all tuning in we'd love to hear from
you in the comments below let us know
your thoughts
check out Joey's website check out him
on Instagram Twitter check on pier 69 as
well as at chubbies podcast those links
are below go check them out give him a
listen also everyone keep supporting
artists and entrepreneurs people that
are taking those risks support them help
people like Joey like us grow our
endeavors and we'll help you as well
this is how we
would everyone much love we greatly
appreciate it shout out to Ron Vargas
the preferred technical director of the
world we love you so much everyone and
we will see you soon
peace